our topic is deviation from the mean
meaning the probability that a random
variable returns a value that differs
significantly from its meaning now the
Markov bound gave you a course bound on
the probability that R was overly large
using very little information about our
not surprisingly if you know a little
bit more about the distribution of R
then it simply that it's not negative
you can state higher bounds then this
was noticed by a mathematician named
chebychev and he has a band called the
chebyshev ban now it's interesting that
the markov bound even though it's very
weak and seems not very useful the
chebyshev bound which generally gives
you a significantly stronger and
valuably stronger bound on the
probability that our random variable
differ as much from its mean is actually
a trivial corollary of Markov theorem so
that's just a very simple ingenious way
to use markoff's bound to derive
chebychev's bound and let's look at how
so we're interested in the probability
that a random variable R differs from
its mean by an amount X the distance
between R and its mean the absolute
value of R - meal is greater than or
equal to X we're trying to get a grip on
that probability as a function of X now
the point is that the event that the
distance between R and its random and
its mean is greater equal to X another
way to say that is to square both sides
of this inequality it says that the
event that R minus mu squared is greater
or equal to x squared it happens these
two events are just different ways of
saying the same thing so therefore their
probabilities are equal trivially now
what's nice about this is of course that
R minus mu squared is a non-negative
random variable to which Markov theorem
applies the square of a real number is
always going to be non-negative so let's
just apply Markov theorem to this new
random variable R minus mu squared and
what does Markov bound tell us about the
this probability
that the square variable is greater than
or equal to an amount x squared well
just plug in Markov and it tells you
that this probability that the square
variable is bigger than by x squared
that it's as big as x squared is simply
the expectation of that squared variable
divided by x squared this is just
applying markups bound to this variable
r minus mu square now this numerator is
a weird thing to stare at expectation of
R minus mu squared and may not seem very
memorable but you should remember it
because it's so important that has
annoying moment name all its own it's
called the variance of R and this is an
extra bit of information about the shape
of the distribution of R that turns out
to allow you to state much more powerful
theorems in general about the
probability that R deviates from its
mean by a given amount so we could just
restate the chebyshev bound just
replacing that expectation formula in
terms of its and its name very and say
all right this is what the chebyshev
bound says the the probability that the
different distance between R and it's
mean is greater than those two X is the
variance of R divided by x squared a
where variance of R is the expectation
of the square of R minus mu now the very
important aspect of technical aspect of
the chebyshev bound is that we're
getting an inverse-square reduction in
the probability remember with Markov it
was a denominator was behaving linearly
and here it behaves quadratically so
these bounds gets get smaller much more
rapidly as we asked about the
probability of differing by a larger
amount the variance of R maybe in a way
that will help you remember it is to
remember another name that it has it's
called the mean square error if you
think of R minus mu as the error that R
is making in how much it differs from
what it ought to be then and we square
it and then we take the average
so we're taking the the mean of the
squared errors and parrot back to
restating the Markov bound in terms of
the variance the variance has one
difficulty with it and that leads us to
want to look at another object which is
just the square root of the variance
called the standard deviation the root
so you wonder why I mean if you
understand variance what's the point of
taking the square root and working with
that and the answer is simply that the
if you think of R as a random variable
whose values have some dimension like
its seconds or dollars then R the
variance of R is the expectation of a
square variable of are minus mu squared
which means it's units are second
squared or dollars squared or whatever
and the variance of R itself is a
squared value which is not reflecting
the magnitude of the of the distance
that you accept the kind of errors that
you expect R to make the distance that
you expect R to be from its mean so we
can get the units of the this quantity
back into matching the units of r and
also get a number that's closer to the
kind of variance that you'd expect to
observe by just taking the square root
and it's called the standard deviation
of our if it helps you any the standard
deviation is also called the root means
square error and you might have heard
that phrase it comes up all the time and
discussions of of experimental error so
again we're taking the error means the
distance between the random variable and
its mean we're squaring it we're taking
it's the expectation of that squared
error and then we're taking the square
root of it it's the standard deviation
so going back to understand what the
standard deviation means intuitively in
terms of a familiar shaped distribution
function for a random variable R suppose
that R is a random variable that has
this fairly standard kind of bell curve
shape or Gaussian shape that it's got
one hump it's you know modal
kind of trails off with some moderate
rate as you get further and further away
from the mean well the mean of of a
distribution that's shaped like this
it's symmetric around that that high
point is that's going to be the mean by
symmetry it's equally likely to be well
the values average out to this middle
value a standard deviation you know for
a curve like this is going to be an
interval that you can interpret as an
interval around the mean and the
probability that you're within that
interval is fairly high for standard
distributions no we'll say that
the championship band is not going to
tell us much about for an arbitrary
unknown distribution but in general for
the typical distributions you expect to
find that the standard deviation tells
you that that's where you're most likely
to be when you take a random value with
the variable so let's return to the
chebyshev bound as we've stayed in it
and I'm just replacing here I'm
restating the chebyshev bound just
replacing the variance of R in the
numerator by the square of its square
root by Sigma squared R it's a useful
way to restate it because by restating
it this way and motivates another
reformulation of the chebyshev found as
we reformulated the markov bound
previously in terms of a multiple of
something I'm going to replace X by a
constant times the standard deviation so
I'm going to see the probability that
the error is greater than or equal to a
constant times the standard deviation
and this term is going to simplify once
X is a constant times the standard
deviation the standard deviations are
going to cancel out and I'm just gonna
wind up with 1 over x squared so let's
just do that and there's the formula the
probability that the distance R from its
mean is greater than or equal to a
multiple C of its standard deviation is
less than or equal to 1 over C squared
so it's getting more much more rapidly
smaller as C grows
let's look at what that means for just
some numbers to make the thing a little
bit more real what this assertion is
telling us is that our is probably not
going to return a value that's a
significant multiple of its standard
deviation for example what is this
formula tell us about the probability
that R is going to be greater than or
equal to one standard deviation away
from its mean well it actually tells us
nothing that's the case in which it's no
good because C is one it's just telling
us that the probability is at most one
which we always know because
probabilities are at most one but if I
ask what's the probability that the mean
if the error of R is regular than or
equal to twice the standard deviation
then this theorem is telling me
something non-trivial it's telling me
that the probability that it's twice the
deviation is 1 over 2 square or 1/4 a
written arbitrary random variable with
standard deviation Sigma is going to
exceed twice the error is going to
exceed twice the standard deviation of
most a quarter of the time three times
at most a ninth of the time four times
at most a sixteenth of them a time
so the the qualitative message to take
away is that for any random variable
whatsoever as long as it has a standard
deviation Sigma then you can say some
definite things about the probability
that the random variable is going to
take a value that differs is by a large
multiple of the standard deviation from
its mean that probability is going to be
small and gets smaller and rapidly
smaller as the multiples of a stand the
a the standard deviation continues